est-ce que vous quitteriez tout pour le
grand amour
non ce que j'ai déjà
alors Adriana comme vous parlez pas très
bien le français je vais vous faire une
interview très simple c'est une
interview à laquelle vous devez répondre
uniquement par oui ou par non et c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle l'interview oui
ou non jingle
[Musique]
you moved
pourquoi on ne bouge pas
[Musique]
ok sur Youtube vous répondez seulement
par oui ou non
est-ce que ça vous gêne de gagner autant
d'argent
non
est-ce que vous en donnez à vos parents
oui
est-ce que vous en donnez aux gens qui
m'ont dit dans la rue oui
est-ce que le luxe vous a rendu plus
capricieux
est-ce que si demain vous rencontriez
dans un avion dans un un homme dont vous
êtes folle est-ce que vous quitteriez
tout pour le grand amour
non ce que j'ai déjà
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà fouillé dans
les poches de Christian
un jour ça peut arriver est-ce que si
vous le trompiez vous lui diriez
est-ce que vous avez réalisé tous vos
fantasmes non non non non
pas possible
si Christian un jour il rentre à la
maison à Madrid et vous trouve lit avec
une autre fille est-ce que vous aurez
est-ce que vous auriez honte
vous pensez à la scène là ouais moi
aussi
tout le monde pense à la scène là c'est
marrant
il y a des blancs il y a des blancs qui
en disent long quand même
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez honte qui vous trouve au lit
avec une autre fille un peu oui si un
jour vous découvrez que Christian
Karembeu est homosexuel est-ce que vous
restez avec lui quand même
et dernière question
quand vous aimez quelqu'un quand vous
aimez vraiment quelqu'un est-ce que vous
pouvez tout faire avec cette personne ah
elle a même pas attendu la fin de la
réponse bravo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu